so for example we want to we have a paid
uh promotion that we want our users to
sign up for it and we decided that
changing the color of the button uh of
the sign up page will make the users
more attractive to sign up for these
actual results so okay so that's a
simple comparison so we just just change
the color of the text
so what do we want so first of all some
terminology we need to know the Baseline
conversion of our experiments So
currently we should know how much is our
conversion rate so we have
um 1 000 users every day and 10 of them
are coming so it's we can Calculate 10
divided by 1000 is going to be our
Baseline conversion rate and why we are
doing this experimentation so we want
our Baseline conversion to grow at least
two percent So based on conversion is
going to be 0.10 and our conversion that
it will desired conversion change should
be 0.02 just 0.2 percent increase among
our users so the main problem uh the
main target for ABX fermentation is it's
first to understand what is going to be
the measurable Target for our
experimentation currently for us it's
going to be to increase the conversion
rate by two percent without starting
I've seen in many
uh use cases that people just run the
experiment without defining what the
metric is going to actually be to be
compared so this is quite wrong because
it's like having the data and then
trying to find something there and just
to have a winner because we want to have
this change this is wrong called
mathematical side
so for example as I couldn't show
anything on my company side so let's
just generate some data so 1000 users
for a variant and 1000 users for our
Burien in reality these numbers aren't
similar they can be the rate the
duration can be even changed 70 30 but
it's good to know how we're actually
doing the targeting so uh when we are
saying a is usually in terminology is
called the control group and when we are
saying B so what to what we are actually
comparing is the test group
so we just make some uh random generated
data so for 2000 users and we're just
gonna assign them to A or B so what vrns
they are going to say we'll talk about
how to do the randomize uh assignment of
experiments in production later before
just to have a mimic of data how it's
going to be
viewed so okay so let's tell also about
them whether they did convert into
variant or not so the First Column shows
whether for example user 0 with index 0
has converted it was in group b and so
on so we have 2 000 users in this list
so they describe the statistics of our
user is gonna be so 90 users converted
from a variant a 128 from B in the
conversions rate you can see on the last
column so actually when we look at the
commercial rates we see that our desired
0.02 is actually exceeded is 0.028 but
is it enough to say that our second
variant is good enough actually no
because we don't have any confidence
among our among our statement if we if I
can get another 1000 users maybe this
ratio can change and we can't even know
what to conclude from this
experimentation
that's why we're going to the stats so
um if we get the distribution of our
control group which you can see is in
the red
I can
this red histogram
so we can actually conclude that our
distribution is binomial because it's
like a coin flip so it's either there is
conversion or there isn't so that's why
it's a binomial distribution is this
line here is actually uh the probability
that our
a b the users from B actually could have
been from distribution of from a
so this line actually as you can see the
line isn't here so the most probable
thing so we can't we don't have any uh
good confidence among to say that it can
be from distribution a
what but this isn't enough to understand
what actually is but what if we just
convert this line to actually a
distribution
so the red one is gonna be about the
distribution of a variant and the second
blue one is the second B variant
distribution
so what can we say here so we don't have
apple to Apple conversion because
comparison because the peaks of their
conversion rates is is this is just a
distribution of their conversion rates
and we actually can't compare we don't
know the how many users they are and
what we're gonna do we're gonna be again
to the Mets
so just to go back a bit to actually do
the Apple to Apple conversion we should
remember what the Bernoulli distribution
is all about so the expectation of
manually distribution is the probability
and the variance is the p uh multiply
one minus P so we don't actually care
now to go to the depot to the stats but
according to the center limit theorem if
we do this experimentation many times
the distribution of sample means will be
normally distributed among the true mean
with the standard deviation equal to the
standard error of the mean so what it
means actually is we'll have this two
histograms here that are going to be
truly compared to each other
so the the axis of here is already
um converted proportion of them and the
dashed lines for each histogram is going
to be the mean that I was telling about
the center for the central limit theorem
so what actually this gives to us is
we currently have these histograms that
we converted by the central limit
theorem and here comes the hypothesis
testing by its origin so the red one as
before
is the a variant and the blue one is the
second variant B variant and some
terminology also here so the null
hypothesis is that there is no
difference among our experimentations so
sometimes we forget uh what the null is
and what is it so for this case the null
hypothesis states there is no difference
so we did the experimentation but we did
see no significant change among the
variants so nothing none is a winner and
but the alternative hypothesis is there
is indeed an improvement among our
experimentation and the Beaver red is
the winner
so what is what can we interpret from
this from this having this chart to
understand whether the our blue line is
better than the red histogram
so
um first of all some metrics that are
using for to actually understand the
performance of the experimentation so is
the chart visible for everyone yeah so
the green one is the statistical power
and it's calculated uh
it's a bit good can you see these dashes
here
the gray dashes
yeah yeah so they're red dashes which
show the confidence interval for our
histograms so from sets we know that if
we want so five percent uh 95 confidence
interval there's first sigmas so it's
this line for
the you see this green and there is one
from here so the statistic power is the
one that lies beyond the 95 percent and
covers the alternative hypothesis this
green one and it shows the statistical
power and the gray dashed lines as I
said is the confidence interval for 95
for the Nile hypothesis statistical
power is calculating uh finding the area
under the alternative hypothesis
distribution and outside the confidence
interval
if I go a bit more so this line so the
one that is inside the uh just to look
the left of dash line but also under the
alternative hypothesis
shows the
the ratio that we accept the alternative
hypothesis and reject the this one shown
this one shows that how confident we are
to accepting the alternative hypothesis
and he this one you can see here is
actually the alpha so it this is the
ratio where
truly eager to sacrifice how the our
confident we can be in accepting our
null hypothesis so when we set it to
five percent it's gonna be the 95
percent that actually structures the
boundary for confidence interval
so
yeah so
actually this is what is actually done
so if it's better than uh the way the
probability of zero zero five zero zero
point zero five we do if it's greater we
do uh accept the null hypothesis and
it's less so we do accept that conclude
that our hypothesis is uh alternative
hypothesis is better so
yeah if we go a bit how it's actually
this math how is all everything converts
to doing production so some tricks uh
from uh production as a product
companies so don't go over go overboard
with segmentation so for example you
have a recommender system that you only
know that your audience is women so you
can show some men clothes to them and to
try to experiment what to show to them
but if you go too broad and only show
them men's top you actually your
experimentation won't be kind of valid
but showing only women clothes isn't
enough because maybe they are trying to
shop for their husband too so this is
some nuances that in production is
coming up so you should always know your
what is your audience
so start big then get smaller so
sometimes uh in production I've seen
that for day targets they are 20 of the
audience and they see no significant
difference among the experiments and
they start to split all the
experimenters by country by gender by
every set just to see something in the
experimentation but this is wrong
because the kind of Baseline to which
the experimentation actually started is
already not equal for them refinector
your segments if you want to refine your
segments you should do from the
beginning not to split up from what you
had a big experiment and then start
doing
so uh during the recessing your tests
yes some tests for example you are
testing some feature but you have many
new users so if you have many new users
you can't actually design there if you
have some feature hidden in the back of
the application for example your new
user's Behavior can be actually
triggered because you have a novelty
effect even for the existing users
returning users having to say something
for example
two new actually one of in the companies
I won't say where so they were wanting
to
increase their call to action for a
specific button but one was static some
small button and the other one they did
this big which one was had an animation
of jumping bunny or something so you
can't do such experiments because the
validation for the
because the second variant was actually
much more visible for the audience than
the one that was just static and some
aesthetic color and it was invisible so
this experimentation to have a call to
action on this second button wasn't a
relevant experiment
so segment by customer value so this is
a good feature so uh in one of the
companies they actually Facebook also
has this approach they are targeting
their best kind of user segment so for
example they are coming 15 days in a
month doing these these sections and
times and we want to kind of there our
best users so doing some experimentation
on these best users actually can tell
you what your best users do want but if
you mix them with them the new users you
actually won't see the results this is a
good thing to segment for example if you
are doing something core for new users
do it for only new users if you are
doing for just for returning ones just
do it for the returning targeting
consider geography and weather so
sometimes if you are a shopping online
market and uh you know that for their
geography reasons that some items aren't
for example selling alcohol to Muslims
isn't a good option to have an
experimentation so just consider user
Geographics and how where they are
settled and all this stuff
and focus on the why of the test not the
what so
many times I've seen in the companies
they said just do all the
experimentation then we'll think do all
experimentation all the time so this is
I think isn't the only always a good uh
kind of approach because you can have
your already slicing your users and
ideally your segments shouldn't overlap
but if you have many experiments and
actually experiment depending on your
traffic should have uh enough for
example it should run two weeks and you
should always be cautious among how many
experiments you are running and as well
said you should know the target for what
you are drawning actually your
experimentation
and another thing I just remembered but
I forgot to add in in the title is uh
what are you do you want to have
overlapping experimentations or not so
doing overlapping experimentation for
example just changing the color and the
text of the button is already
overlapping experimentation and this is
a whole new story so you should do
multivariant a b testing here so
sometimes they do change everything and
want to compare with this approach no
novelty effect is here and too many
aspects are affecting it
so is it good to run several experiments
simultaneously sometimes yes sometimes
no so for example I'm if you're changing
something on let's take the product that
everybody knows for for Facebook so so
you're changing the icon for profile
for the landing page that you the user
should Target and then you are changing
something on the profile page to test on
the experiment how it's running actually
you can do it if you do the on the same
segment of users because they are
overlapping the same users has many
experimentations on just running for
only for them but if you do change
something on the profile and put
something on the feed maybe they don't
affect it so the user can participate in
two experiments simultaneously
so when to interpret the results uh as
we were talking about the alpha and beta
so this is the sacrifice that we are
actually eager to
do to run the experimentation just let
me so Evan I like this calculator very
much so this is Evan Miller's a b
testing calculator so this is the
Baseline conversion rate for example we
have 20 percent conversion for this
feature and we want to see the five
percent
effect for our alternative hypothesis so
this calculator says and here you can
see that we have the statistical power
that we're seeing in the histograms and
the significance for five percent so
five percentage five percent and eighty
percent is the kind of Statistics uh
kind of foundation so this book
conversion rate
um I'll find better that usually people
start with but if your product is too
sensitive you can set this up to five
one percent and have 99 of confidence
interval to make sure that that your
experimentation is really the one that
you want to change so here if we have 20
percent and five percent detectable
effect is we just need 1030. uh sample
users per variant but what will happen
if I decrease the minimum effect who can
say the sample size will increase or
decrease
increase
increase yeah so is this the touch I
don't know
so if I said just one percent 25 how
much it should increase so what if the
Baseline conversion rate is lower will
it affect the sample size
if I changed it to two percent to sink
two percent in two percent chasing one
percent change is different than saying
one percent change in 20 percent change
so they how you design actually your
experimentation is gonna be decide when
your experimentation is going to be
stopped and
so this is actually if your traffic
isn't good enough so you can run for two
weeks or not so and also some notes on
when to run the experimentation if you
are doing something related for example
to a new year and it's a period of New
Year okay you can do experiments among
the new year but if you're doing some
experimentation on generic some feature
and you are doing push notifications and
campaigns and increasing your traffic
this experimentation isn't going to be
true value because you have artificial
flow not artificial but artificial for
the ABX fermentation and not related to
the experimentation itself
and
coming back to the
second
so related to when to interpret the
results whenever you have enough sample
size you should stop it
so do we need to revisit the already
completed experiments so this is the
validation step so sometimes people
don't want to actually change do want to
change the variant but they decided to
keep the kind of initial variant because
the experimentation wasn't good enough
and they want to revisit they already
completed experiment and to kind of
restore what the initial experimentation
was but this is quite dependent on how
much traffic and load you can have and
this is a bit tricky depending on your
product because you should have the same
setup for your experimentation
uh what are AAA experiments so a
experiments sometimes people do this
experimentation before running a b
experimentation so this is helping to
understand whether your experience is
set up technical setup is working so if
you see kind of the alternative
hypothesis is winning uh in AAA
experimentation which is the same
variant all two groups are seeing the
same variant but I don't know why the
second group is actually performing
better so maybe you had your
randomization or something is broken on
this code side maybe you have a bug so
running a experimentation will help you
to understand whether your expectation
technical setup is actually working and
then to do a AP experimentation just on
the top of it
this will help you to eliminate the
technical
difficulties and kind of bugs on that
side also related to randomizations so
some companies are using actual tools
they are buying for for example
optimizely to run their experiments but
some are just building their tools I'm
saying itself doing the Frameworks and
things themselves and actually this is
some tricky part in one of the companies
so they decided to for each user were
assigned to special number which was the
order how they are going to be
participating in the experiments so
whenever one user we're participating in
the experiment and the experiment was
stopped he was always assigned to a new
experiment but the users which had a
bigger number never actually
participated in experiments so their
randomization of the experiments set up
was actually a buggy so you shouldn't do
such things you every time you should
check uh whether you want exclusive or
exclusive experiments whether you want
your users to overlap in other
experiments or not this is something to
test so many times to running with a
experiments you will kind of test these
buggy things to understand whether your
users are always or are the same segment
of users always participating in
experiments the other aren't or are not
and yeah so maybe we can head to the
questions if you have one
foreign
thank you very much for a great talk
um I have a question related to the
expected increase of the conversion we
mentioned
since we like were were lower expected
conversion we need higher like the
bigger bigger sample doesn't mean that
we can stop the experiment earlier if we
if we spot like higher conversion yeah
you are kind of tweaking your experiment
to see your result desired result so
this thing should be done before running
the experiment because it's something
because if you are doing experiment
maybe you actually want the B to win and
sometimes I I was saying that
PM's product managers are always
refreshing the dashboard to see oh a new
user account came and they clicked this
button yay so but after a week the it
just kind of slowed down you can't stop
before you have the desired sample
enough sample size
instead of two we need five uh the
sample size of five thousand percent of
000. like you will already have like one
five thousand uh visitors and we already
see like the increase of uh decrease of
the conversion by five percent that we
see that it's uh like I mean
I'm a bit skeptical to stopping it
because the difference among this is too
high
so
what kind of experiment should it be to
have this kind of increase so actually
the difference among the experiments
let's be frank isn't this we don't see
this much change actually in among the
experiments to get this low sample size
because if we are changing the color we
are changing the text we can change many
things on the page and we don't run
campaigns simultaneously so
actually I wouldn't stop it so you don't
trust statistics too much right no I
wouldn't stop it I like the kind of
start I believe in initial setup because
man it's always validate violated yeah
uh my question is also about the second
size but the
I guess the more complete position is
the second third capital is used
to be to be using a of B groups so this
is for for variant so this is user's
current count per variant
so the total is going to be 50 000.
super very
people in each of the groups yeah for
example if you have three variants
you'll need three times this number
you it's not always comparing A and B
you can have ABC you can have ABCD okay
so let me put it suppose we have a
e-commerce website and we want to see a
certain page layouts
and you take 2 000 users and you divide
them into 1000 units
okay so maybe not four thousand of them
or maybe not about two thousand of them
this is the site in the next month or
two
more view okay with this or this is what
I was talking about what you are
actually experimenting if you're
experimenting for the your returning
users you should Target them so you
should assign the randomized versioning
only to them not to older users
yeah so if you're a 367
yeah depending on what you're actually
testing if you are testing the sign up
page this is definitely the new users if
you're testing something on setting page
for profile maybe they are actually the
signed up users and you I think some
hidden page is gonna be should wait
longer to run because it's too too many
steps the user to should do it to come
there and even calculating the
conversion rate is sometimes too tricky
so you should always be cautious what
you put the actual funnel for your user
is what's the beginning of the
conversion rate the Baseline to convert
is to calculate is more tricky okay in
other words the
the
I guess the sample size in each of the
groups
do they all have to go do the
experimental
yeah no not so what is guys for example
it's actually a trigger on the page for
example I'm I'm testing something on
Facebook profile page until the user
hasn't come to the profile page take
experiment parent easily decided to them
okay yeah so you come here do the
trigger start and the action should be I
don't know to add there is some photo
section there do this section the
conversion should be compared with these
numbers the user groups are not deciding
ahead of time yeah actually that's
better yeah
but depending on the experiment if your
experiment is starting from the
beginning it's better to decide the
threshold where the kind of the
experiment should trigger and what this
is the success rate uh the success
criteria for the experiment to be to be
considered as a success
it's not always going to be equal to
equal but as I said in a experimentation
you should see that the variants are
equally considered
also yeah you can I'll continue you can
tell
yeah can you speak up
um first a comment and then a question
um the question about stopping there's a
really interesting article uh it's a
really interesting article called the
peaking problem I think it's from
Shopify about yeah how to or why it's so
dangerous to stop the experiment early
and it's got really nice graphs to show
it and then my question was um yeah
because we're starting to try some
incrementality testing in my work which
is actually more what I would call this
and the best packages we've found so far
as geolift from Facebook but it's in R
this is the fashion conference do you
have other packages you could recommend
for this
um yeah so actually we are building our
framework ourselves
so maybe I can tell a bit a background
and then come to your question so
currently in our company we're doing uh
we want to do our data science machine
learning models experimentations and we
actually have a problem to Define what
is actually user here so is it for
example
um I'm coming from service Titan we have
technicians who go to the onsite and do
some recommendations to their clients
what should be installed in their house
so what is the user here if I have a
recommendation algorithm here so is it
the technician session is it the tenant
itself for all his clients should always
say the same or it says they every time
the technician is searching something
what's the experiment where you want to
to be assigned actually this is a huge
problem to understand what is it and
referring to your question we are
building our framework ourselves we
don't use anything yeah
in my previous companies the one was
built from scratch and the other was
using optimizely
so external just tooling and Facebook
Facebook also has a baby experimentation
and Firebase also has it
so yeah just defining even defining the
user is not user session what is it it's
quite difficult to truly understand when
should it be and we're in discussion so
whether it should be the technician
session until they log out kill the
application or it's just every time they
search or
for all employees for this specific
clients you see the same experimentation
so it's in in B2B it's more harder to do
and when in b2c so in for I come from
Pixar so there are many millions of
users coming every day so you can just
segment some part of them and they're
gonna come so the flow of the
application is popular the users and
statistically if you have many the
population is quite big enough you can
have some confidence in the results but
if you are B2B and into B2B for example
in our product
employees are getting trained even
having employees being trained is how
the the whole segment of the tenants
employees are going to be behave the
same so how to do it so even that kind
of stuff is really hard actually to do
I can see
sorry
[Music]
before you start your a b testing
experiment
will have just you know select run on
selection with highest size is enough or
do you think
you need a kind of you know drag other
other kpls for example you you want to
launch or launch a button or maybe a
landing page and you want to compare you
know two group of users do you for
example compare their logins or maybe
other performance in advance format so
usually we compare some metrics but only
one metric is considered as a winner for
the experiment station setup I've seen
many times that they are calculating
tens ten metrics and when in one metric
they see significant difference in the
experimentation say this is the winner
no it's not yeah it's kind of cherry
picking the metrics with the one that
you actually do want and just to make
sure that the variant you do want is a
winner I have I have even saying that
TCR said this variant should go we are
just stopping the experimentation so
when why did you run the experimentation
in that case so this is just a waste of
resources because this user if someone
wants the other PM wants to run an
experiment which should be only
exclusive so this user shouldn't
participate in other experiments so you
are just taking the user from the other
product that should test something on
them
no more questions
thanks for the presentation I was
wondering how the community with small
amount of places
controlled so if you can't wait there's
a small amount of time
um
besides like having to move because yeah
you shouldn't do it experimentation in
that case because the product shouldn't
tell you how long the experiment should
run this is math
which approach
yeah Bayesian approach is yeah more
kind of more I like that approach more
so
this is going to be included on our
framework to decide how we're gonna
actually today for for each model we're
gonna decide so we don't have this
problem of common users but Bayesian
approach is more much more
understandable because if you tell the
PM the I have 95 percent confidence
interval confidence that this this is
disappeared the EPM doesn't understand
what is your 95 percent of confidence
the Beijing approach is much more easy
to interpret and easy to understand
yeah thank you so much